thank you so much for sitting down with
us today sterling before you talk about
get seriously talk about Angry Birds I
just want to say congratulations on this
is us getting renewed from three more
seasons what was your initial reaction
when you found out about that I know I
saw the Twitter video but was like your
initial was your initial reaction joy
man I mean that's my family
you know both literally and figuratively
on that show so to know that I get three
more years to spend time with family is
a blessing you know I get a chance to be
home in LA doing a job that means a lot
to me with people who I love so it's the
best and you also originally announced
that you will be on the third season of
marvelous mrs. Mayes oh how did that
even come about because I know there
were some Twitter action going man so
I'm a fan of the show like I think what
the Paladino have created is so rich and
beautiful in the way that it's shot and
just so witty in its wordplay and so I
just said to Rachel and I saw her one
day I was like if I could do your show I
would be happy and so she passed that
along to them and they're like are you
serious I'm like I'm serious and then
one thing led to another and Here I am
oh man I'm excited about that so I
noticed you did a little bit of voice
work before this but this is like your
main first feature yeah how was it was
there any differences or anything like
that man
it's so different from live-action
because you're using just your voice to
to bring this character to life whereas
you have your face and your body and
everything else at its disposal so you
my voice was getting tired so I had to
really learn how to do things in a way
that I could do almost like a play like
eight shows a week you got to keep doing
it over and over and over again so I had
a lot of Ricola I got a lot of tea I had
a lot of water and I also had a lot of
fun because you do it six seven eight
different ways and you start to hone in
on one thing that's working in
particular so yeah it was a lot of
exploration until you find that thing
that clicks and can you tease a little
bit about your character and who you're
playing in this movie yeah man I'm Gary
the pig who's an inventor who's either
too good at his job or not good enough
and what I mean by that is he makes
invisible spray that turns people
invisible but they can't come back from
being invisible right he makes an eagle
detector there's very good at detecting
Eagles but it's also incredibly loud and
lets Eagle to know that you're around so
if he was better this job
people could probably come back from
being invisible and the eagle detector
would not be able to detect you as well
the Eagles but he's sort of my ode to Q
from the James Bond movies the inventor
yeah and in those films and so it's just
it was fun dude it was fun to do an
accent to be a little silly to do
something completely different than what
people are accustomed to see me do yeah
your character well soon as you came
on-screen I was instantly laughing with
those with those inventions that he had
I know you also have another animated
movie coming up later on can you tease
anything with that about that no idea
what you're talking about
okay can we expect any bloopers from
this movie any deleted scenes that
didn't make the cut that you just improv
so I mean there's a lot of improvisation
that went into the film and like I know
there's some things that didn't make the
final cut so hopefully if they do a
little blooper reel your boy will be
present in that as well all right
awesome and well thank you so much for
sitting down with Collider we you love
this movie it can't wait for people to
see you appreciate you Brian thank you